health care is the most information
intensive industry in the economy and it
uses information technology the least of
any industry in the economy so if you
think about where do we need information
to most it's clearly health care you
need to know what's going on with the
patient what they're allergic to what
kinds of issues they have what treatment
options and yet we still do things by
paper and pencil storing things in huge
stacks where you can't retrieve them and
they're not there where you need them
health care is amongst the lowest
productivity industries in the economy
if you look at the well performing
industries they tend to have three
features the productive industry scent
of three features first they use
information technology a lot they know
who's doing what why they're doing it
how rapidly they're doing it what the
outcome is how to improve it they're
always thinking about that they use
information technology a lot in
healthcare we don't second they have
compensation arrangements that are tied
to improving value when employees create
value they get paid more when when they
do things that don't create value they
don't get paid as much in healthcare you
get paid for doing things for volume but
not for value and third is they they
decentralize it so that changes are made
by workers workers have authority the
famous Toyota model any worker can stop
the production line why because he or
she has the right information and the
right incentives to make sure that the
cars are coming out with the quality
that they need to in health care the
frontline workers are so busy just
getting by that they don't have the
opportunity to do better if you take
those nurses who are spending a third of
their time documenting things and say
well couldn't we do better they'd say
yes but I just don't have the time to
figure out how I'm so rushed I can't
figure it out Healthcare has got to get
better it's got to get better on the
information end where we've made a good
start with the recent American Recovery
and Reinvestment Act which is spending
30 billion dollars on health IT
compensation changes what you need to
follow that hopefully in health care
legislation that comes this fall that
say we pay more for value and not just
for volume and organizational changes
freeing up organizations and helping
them learn from each other so that they
say hey you know what I really can read
this a high-performing enterprise this
doesn't have to be an enterprise that's
got low productivity
it come back to the most productive
businesses the ones that have
increasingly lower costs those are
businesses that are actually the most
innovative not the least innovative if
you look at the most productive
industries in the economy their
industries like information technology
like retail trade like agriculture that
use technology the most but they
directed the right way for people to
think that healthcare reform is going to
involve stifling innovation is just
absolutely wrong if we do it right we
are going to open the possibilities for
enormous amounts of innovation we just
give you a different example than what
we've seen take them take the
antidepressant drugs just as one example
it is a well-known fact that
antidepressant drugs the same drug will
work on some patients and not work on
others just give give people paxil or
give people prozac or give them celexa
or whatever it is some patients respond
to it other patients don't and it's
different some people respond to one
medication some people respond to
another some people respond to a third
but not to the others why is that well
we don't know there's surely something
biological about it when you switch
people from one drug to another you you
wind up sometimes getting them to
respondent getting better well with a
little bit of innovation will be able to
figure out which patients will respond
better to which drugs as a result we can
avoid giving people drugs are not going
to respond to wasting money wasting
treatment the people don't come back
because the thing is not working even
worse with some kind of chemotherapy
agents where the patient dies in the
interim with innovation will be able to
figure out how to tailor what you need
what you get to what you need in
addition to all the other things we're
talking about so we'll have a medical
care system that's actually customized
for you not just for something generic
not just hey we just start on this
because this is what we do and if you
don't respond better it's your
responsibility for figuring out how to
do something different that's just one
example of where we're going to need a
lot of innovation healthcare reform has
to encourage innovation across the board
or else it's not going to succeed